台灣股市又是急拉尾盤的一天
昨天急殺尾盤
今天急拉尾盤
台股感覺好像弱勢
結果最後答案居然是莫名其妙的強勢
為什麼 因為AI時代來臨了
今天三大重點
台股急拉尾盤大漲693點
9月魔咒要被破除了嗎
今天有個9月魔咒
因為今天晚上8點半的就業數據
如何解讀
因為這個就業數據加上通膨數據
決定了9月要不要升息
一升息股市會動盪
第二個 國巨 華新科漲停
被動元件還能追嗎
不離不棄 是我兄弟
勇者無懼 就等國巨
我今天盤中在Threads的時候
發個文章 沒想到國巨漲停了
投資朋友
最有Guts的分析師就是我啦
你看到所有很多投顧的分析師
我不是要攻擊誰 我講事實
國巨不行了 換一檔股票
再不行換一檔股票
每天有漲停板
你真的相信他們講的話
這樣你受傷剛好
國巨1200 1000元 800元
我就叫你走掉 你不理我
500多元打個對折
不是耶 現在打4折
4折多你們不要
我管你那些什麼法人賣不賣
你不要開玩笑
你要不要看一下欣興
奇怪 今天一堆人
天上的欣興不說話 為什麼
不漲價了啦
欣興不行了
8046南電為什麼不行
為什麼跌那麼慘
這一波欣興 南電根本沒漲
你知不知道去年這個時候
欣興 南電 你們看一下就好
給你看2025 看一下
2025查一下
你們看一下
欣興那時候100多塊有沒有看到
投信都在賣
100多塊投信都在賣啦
我照樣買啊 外資都在賣
再拉遠一點
大部分投信都在賣 這邊
更早更慘 來看一下
看一下更慘 我們看一下
等我一下
2月 3月的時候我被很多人罵
看一下價錢
你們看了會覺得誇張
投信是不是都在賣
外資每天都賣欣興 為什麼
因為那時候欣興90幾塊 100塊
我被人罵的跟什麼一樣
I don't care
我從頭到尾就人棄我取 人取我與
奇怪 股價漲了10倍你們幹嘛追
我也不懂為什麼一些主動型ETF
要買ABF載板
這就是主動型ETF最大問題
他容易追高殺低
沒辦法 為了績效
我不一定 我覺得所謂的績效是等來的
你不相信我 你參加別人的我沒差
我不缺會員 投資朋友
沒有辦法 不是我講話跩
我本來就財富自由了
因為我的Style就是這樣子
寧可你少受傷
買台灣50正2我可以賺比較多
我寧願覺得你買台灣50比較好
你看那時候都在賣
都在賣 投信都在賣
外資一直連賣 偶而才買一下
投信大部分賣 投信根本不理他
100多塊的時候像垃圾
900多塊 1000多塊
我跟你講說天上的欣興不說話
我暗示你了
地上的南電叫媽媽 媽媽
你們為什麼不買低基期的股票
奇怪 國巨現在賣
國巨現在投信一堆人在賣
不就等同於去年70塊的欣興
去年70塊的欣興耶
7 80塊的欣興
一樣啊 投信不要你 外資不要你
不重要 郭哲榮要你就好了
我說漲就漲
我叫你All in就All in
我叫你重壓就重壓
我叫你漲就漲 我叫你跌就跌
我叫你買就買
想那麼多幹嘛
哪個分析師這麼有Guts 你告訴我
你們真的要相信
那種每天有漲停板的老師
拜託 請你退出股市
退出我的頻道
我也建議你退出股市
你遲早被人家騙走 賠大錢
現在股市哪有那麼好操作
你們講的那些人
去參加選股比賽
要嘛不敢參加
要嘛參加選股比賽
真的績效都很差
跟你講天天漲停板的
都是這種結局
相信我
不可能的啦
我們摩爾很多分析師都經得起考驗
不可能的
真的 你要知道
當然其他同業你也不需要攻擊我
第一個 我不會特別針對誰
我只會針對一個現象
第二個
我認為我們摩爾投顧有把餅做大
消滅我們不一定比較好
這個跟大家講
上一個攻擊我們的
搞得自己身體不好
營收沒有比較好
真的都沒必要
我都祝福大家
只是我覺得我們要以正視聽
我希望這邊業界越來越多
是以績效為主的分析師
不是用講的分析師
投資朋友 你看這個股票
這幾天很多人還亂謠傳
講得好像我1000塊國巨
1000塊國巨跟我有什麼關係
900塊國巨跟我也沒關係
800塊國巨跟我也沒關係
700塊國巨跟我也沒關係
600元以上的國巨跟我也沒關係
那我的勝算那麼高
為什麼不做 是不是
聽你的話 國巨就價差
國巨你現在做很多價差也賺錢
Threads好多冒牌哲哲
我跟你講 Threads真的太多了
你知道我一天要刪幾個嗎
我一天至少刪60個假的
導播應該也幫我刪了幾個吧
一天至少100個
我都不知道
Threads的假帳號這麼好申請
光是我自己的
我一天可以刪 我們可以
就是我發文章都是
就是那種比較講一些幹話
比較好笑的就是我
那可是導播會幫我上影片
他會順便幫我刪留言
幫我封鎖一些留言
導播一天應該封鎖我4 50個有吧
超過
我至少 我自己有時候
一天60個以上
一天100個
他們一個月下來
可以有3000個哲哲假帳號
我也很佩服他們 好有毅力喔
他們為什麼不做別的事情呢
有這麼厲害的毅力
應該做別的事情更好賺錢
好辛苦喔
我好辛苦 他們也好累
我也好累 來 我跟你講喔
只要邀請你加入哲哲群組的
有群組的都是詐騙
而且我不會主動
我不會私訊或只是在留言說
請你加我的LINE
這就是一個貼圖你知道嗎
很多人不知道這是貼圖
幫我添加管理
這是假的喔
還有一些人就是在用比較老招的
把這個IG跟Threads的影片
改編
然後把它蓋住
蓋成另外一個LINE
反正100個只要騙到1個就夠了
他們是這樣的想法
不行喔 所以我就說
我最喜歡是YT
因為YT只要有假影片
修改我的影片 修改我的Threads
可以直接下架
而且直接封鎖他
所以我最討厭是臉書
YouTube
就是YouTube影片比較好
造假的話就直接把你BAN掉
把你電話給禁止掉
臉書跟Threads
可以申請很多假帳號
YouTube比較難
所以記得
一切的真實狀況以YT為主
這樣懂不懂 OK嗎
然後我不會主動叫你加LINE
哲哲不需要 懂嗎
這個跟大家講
人紅是非多
不想花這些時間 很累 來
我刪模仿你的詐騙留言
詐騙仔還會私訊罵我
對啊 他們就賺不到業績啊
拜託不要找我
我也會彈鋼琴
我等等可以幫你伴奏 不用了
我昨天買國巨520 我愛你
跟今天漲停板把它賣掉 真厲害
YT真的
Threads我也有真的啊
看藍勾勾 好不好
他們很聰明嘛
對 看藍勾勾對不對
譬如說這個藍勾勾是我嘛 對不對
然後他就截圖改變
藍勾勾帳號是我的對不對
這個LINE不是我的
我沒有要叫你加LINE
好不好 叫你加LINE
主動叫你加LINE的就不是我 OK嗎
這就是截圖改的
這雖然是我
他只是模仿我的名義 OK嗎
然後用一張圖片
不是我真實發言
是用圖片改的文字 懂不懂
以這個為主
然後這個為主裡面
如果有圖片敘述你
有告訴你要加LINE
也不要相信
因為那是用圖片修改的 OK嗎
這樣懂不懂
不要看到有人
看疑似是我叫你主動加LINE
就相信了 OK
華新科漲停 謝謝哲神
Lily的事情
Lily我就跟大家
Lily稍微講一下
就是說主持人這方面
我覺得哲哲可能也比較嚴格
所以以後我可能真的
你們看到之前上一個主持人以後
其實我就一段時間沒找
那Lily我也比較少找她
因為其實你們看到
我給他訓練時間
我怕給他壓力
因為其實他比較沒有
之前沒有工作經驗
這個因為人家年輕
所以我覺得以後我可能會
他可能比較想往音樂這方面走
可能以後我這個節目
不一定會找主持人
這個跟大家講
可是哲哲有缺秘書
如果你們真的自認為耐操
缺秘書
然後也會開車最好
這個跟大家講
哲哲有時候還是要處理事情
那當然我就誠徵秘書
好不好 這個跟大家講
以後可能就不找主持人
誠徵秘書
年薪基本上可以100
120萬以上也可以
這個跟大家講
秘書其實也不需要做很多事
就是處理我一些事情就好
公事 公事
當然也有一些私人的事情
我個人私人的事情
不需要每天陪我吃飯 OK嗎
司機 因為司機我更少
我很少出去
我只要進辦公室
我基本上我也出不了
只是會開車最好
這個跟大家講
要坐大腿 不用
秘書不用坐大腿 OK
導播在
導播 我怕被性騷擾
好不好 OK嗎 這個跟大家講
來 今天好High嗎
AI女秘書有考慮嗎
好啦 沒有秘書也沒差啦
這個跟大家講
因為其實公司還是很多人可以幫我做
助理可以幫我處理
很多人幫我處理
只是我想找一個專一的
導播會煮牛肉麵
為什麼大家很喜歡你
這個跟大家講
會煮牛肉麵 不用凌晨4點
凌晨4點傳出去能聽嗎
哲哲叫秘書凌晨4點煮牛肉麵
這個跟大家講 來
我們來跟大家講 來
不會啦 其實哲哲都祝福每一個人
但是哲哲真的
我自己覺得我自己
也可能自己比較龜毛一點
這都有差 這都有差
所以我覺得自己要求自己最快
要求別人 我覺得有時候人家可能
不一定 我覺得每一個人想法不同
我就跟大家講
多說我覺得沒什麼意思
我覺得因為多說 每個人
說者無意 聽者有心
我覺得怕大家誤會
我只要告訴大家
我覺得我現在 我覺得每一件事情
我也不勉強大家 也不勉強任何人
我也不勉強我自己 就這麼簡單而已
所以我做節目就是做開心
你聽不聽 像我的節目
聽不聽隨便你
國巨你聽不聽隨便你
我已經告訴你風險
你不要斷章取義我的話
1000塊以上跟我沒關係
國巨你不要哪天大跌
這是我講的名言
你不要賺錢沒來謝謝我
賠錢都來怪我
那最好你賺錢也不要謝謝我
不要 我不需要你參加
如果你是賠錢想要怪東怪西的
拜託不要找我 這個我跟大家講
好不好 大家都開開心心過每一天
好不好 這個跟大家講
你阿嬤會唱海波浪 可以嗎
那個秘書最好是要會用AI
因為做很多事情規劃
比如說我的私人行程
比如說規劃休息的時候
像我自己規劃行程
我想給你看我規劃行程表
我都寫得很好
比那種旅行社
就是我們員工旅行不是要去布拉格嗎
然後去布拉格 我們有連續住三晚
一晚都2 3萬塊的
叫什麼 金色什麼
布拉格 金色費爾蒙
他說歐洲很有名的
扯遠了啦 就是那個
我把我的行程 比如說去日本的行程
去九州福岡的行程
或是九州的行程
我用AI做的圖比旅行社做得還漂亮
還更仔細
還有備註怎麼樣 雨天方案
這個跟大家講
今年去哪邊玩 我只要假日的時候
我今年去哪邊玩 蠻多的
可是我都是利用休息的時候
我不敢在非假日的時候出去玩
你們沒發現嗎
我有在非假日的時候出去玩嗎
有的話都是錄完影
一到五我基本上就在台灣 你懂不懂
都一定利用假日
因為我也會放不下大家 好不好
今天要唱歌嗎 好不好
為什麼今天比較晚開講 有嗎
沒有 其實我是遲刻魔 好不好
這祝福每一個人 都祝福每一個人
來 這個跟大家講
來 我們來看一下
這個都不是重點 就像哲哲一樣
女主持人也好 男主持人也好
分析師也好 重點還是賺錢
但是都謝謝大家啦
謝謝你們 來 我們來看一下
我們看一下這個東西 我們來看一下
今天晚上很重要
為什麼我說今天晚上很重要
我們剛剛講到國巨以後
我們來看一下今天晚上
今天晚上最重要的是非農的就業數據
失業率有沒有看到 維持4.1%
今天預期維持4.1%
你看這是我們做的AI圖
對 我來喝個水
因為今天這個很重要
我們先講今天總體經濟以後
再跟你講說AI的進展
昨天很多人說我像預言家
的確 很多人要失業
我再講一次
你們以後很多人要失業了
不要覺得不可能
要改變行業
客服行業 駕駛行業好不好
要注意一下 一定要改變
你不知道怎麼改變 沒辦法
因為很多人不是像哲哲一樣
這麼有意志力
那你先投資股票
不知道 買台灣50
想要分散風險 買台灣50
跟買00662 分散風險
00662應該要寫惠我良多
我沒有拿他們一毛錢
我就是要推薦
就是要你10年後謝謝我
你10年後會愛上我
不要買了一點點就賣了好不好
放久一點 放久一點
那我們來看一下
先來看一下我們的簡訊
因為今天國巨漲停嘛 對不對
沒錯嘛 華新科也漲停
你看我們昨天是買276
昨天買的 昨天有叫人家買進
昨天一直有新會員買 276買進的
賺到了
我們華新科 我們國巨
國巨是大部分人賺錢
華新科是所有人都賺錢
強調一件事
只要有買進華新科的所有會員們
有買進華新科的會員們
通通都賺錢
來 恭喜恭喜
來 幫我念一下 導播
好 9月4號禮拜五 今天的簡訊
恭喜2492華新科
股價開高走高 直接衝上漲停
我們昨天才剛進場加碼
今天馬上噴出
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
賺大錢啦 好不好
恭喜大家賺大錢 有沒有看到
股價開高走高 直接衝上漲停
持股獲利續抱
這個跟大家講
所以這個節目都是
一定有新面孔 老面孔
你看導播就是
現在就是一直要抱著我
導播也來多久 5 6年了 對
也是一樣
導播來多久 3年了
這個跟大家講
每個人想法不同
台積電都有人員流動
可是我覺得
我從現在開始應該就是我一個人
因為哲哲有時候講話思緒太快
我覺得我也會給人家壓力
好不好 來
而且有時候我比較要求
所以我都是這樣子
我們昨天 這個就最後一次講這個了
我們昨天才剛進場加碼
今天馬上噴出
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
衝上漲停
華新科 衝漲停
國巨 衝漲停
國巨我發文的時候還沒有漲停
就是說不離不棄 是我兄弟
勇者無懼 就等國巨
不恐不懼 就等國巨
國巨給我尾盤拉了
我都不知道我的Threads
是不是有影響力
恭喜2327國巨股價開高大漲
尾盤衝上漲停 手上持股抱好抱牢
國巨噴出去 我跟你講一件事啦
你們看這些新聞 來看一下
國巨 這是舊的
可是我跟你講這個都
MLCC供需愈來愈緊了
不要說舊的
就是近期的 不是這一天的
分銷商庫存創新低
股價再漲7% 有沒有看到
為什麼 因為庫存量減了8%
創史上新低 庫存金額成長
我告訴你 人家台積電都說了
就算20個廠建立完成以後
馬上建立完成了 還在缺
AI需求無上限 Google講的
你們都不理我
我就跟你講了
請你們拜託
你知不知道我
我真的不是我要臭美
我從小到大 我考試還不錯
常常第一名
但是我覺得我最強的是什麼
理解邏輯跟問問題能力
AI跟我就如虎添翼
真的會AI的人
真的一個人可以抵100個
我現在可以自己做圖 設計圖
像那個設計師
我最近有要裝潢
設計師說他不行
我說不行
假設他做個圖 他說不行
他不行 我假設這個
我舉個例好了
你等一下看
我說我真的很會問問題
他們說不會用
我就說只是你不會用
等一下
好啦 我用嘴巴講好了
嘴巴講比較快
就是我給他一張圖
就這張圖片
網路上不是有設計圖嗎
裝潢設計圖
然後設計師說他不會用
我遇到設計師說不用
然後遇到律師跟我講說他不好用
結果被我說服後
然後我教他們怎麼用以後
結果他就覺得很好用
所以你們是不會用AI而已
我從小到大最會問問題
譬如說一個圖片
一張圖片我只是問他說
等一下 先不要轉過來
先看
要看什麼東西 等一下
算了 好多是私人的 不要看了
根本不是我的問題都看了
那不是重點
我怕大家看到 因為太多了
你知道我一下子問了
那個導播可能不小心看到
很多根本就是朋友的問題
還有我的問題 2 30個
我每天一天都問2 30個問題
我就不給你們看我的問題
可是我其中一個問題
我因為臨時找 找不到
害我害羞起來
那個設計師就問一張
就是一張很漂亮的圖片
就是裝潢圖片
然後設計師說這個圖片沒有用
我不能用成我要用的
就是他不能參考模仿
我說你只要一張漂亮的圖片
裝潢好的圖片
網路上都可以找得到
蒐集起來以後
他說那沒辦法
我叫他比例也問不清楚
我說你要問清楚
比如說你要問立面圖
我說專有名稱叫立面圖
立面圖它還是沒有幾公分
我說你要問清楚
這個家具要幾公分 每一件要標示
那AI就懂了你的意思了
它就設計得非常清楚了
所以連設計師也好
它現在可以模仿人家的裝潢
然後只要一張照片就好
它就可以比例出來 每一個
那你要跟他講比如說這個
因為300公分的高度
跟250公分高度不一樣 每個房間
假設我現在這裝潢是300公分的
沒關係 我有客戶是280公分的
那280公分的
300公分的這張圖改成280公分
然後你每一張的
比如說尺寸 衣櫃 鞋櫃的尺寸
長寬高列出來
他說很準
我就是問法不一樣 你懂嗎
因為我很會用AI
我告訴大家為什麼
所以我會越來越需要
那當我慢慢教大家的時候
或者說有人像我這樣教
他們遲早會學會
那這個AI的需求只會越來越高
那被動元件我跟你講 他就會拉起來
被動元件只漲幾倍 漲一倍而已
我都不懂
你們為什麼要買漲十倍的股票
除了記憶體以外
因為記憶體超級有夠缺
不然我真的不建議你
去買那種十倍的股票
我就不懂 天上的欣興不說話
70塊我被人家罵得要死
700塊 1000塊你問我幹嘛
那不是跟國巨一樣嗎
都一樣 為什麼我今年績效那麼好
哲哲就是買低的股票
我就不想追高
我盡量不追高
我不能說我完全不追高
我盡量就不追高
所以我今年績效為什麼那麼好
你看有些人都每天漲停板
你真的相信喔
不要胡扯
真的 今年不好做
尤其6月以後不好做
可是我跟你講 我實實在在的
國巨就是這樣子
被動元件庫存就下滑啦
你再看這個東西 我再跟你講這個東西
現在最恐怖是什麼
助理你再幫我做一下
我有叫助理做這個東西
請你做一個最新的圖 什麼圖
最新的不是
OpenAI GPT-6 Astra嗎
你知道現在一堆模型嗎
有什麼Pro3.1啊
Gemini Pro3.1啊
好像是什麼Flash版本啊
加深度思考
我的意思是說
我應該做一張圖片給你看
以前是幾個月更新一次
現在是一個月
基本上是一兩個月更新一次
以前是半年更新一次
現在是一兩個月或一個月裡面
好多的程式都在更新
這就是我說的什麼
AI以後進步會越來越快
來 你們要懂喔
那些說AI是泡沫的人
根本就不懂什麼叫AI
再看一次
因為你們以前說汽車發展啊
是這樣發展對不對
電動車是這樣發展對不對
我跟你講 以後AI的成長是這樣子
基本上是90度
它也不是45度
這樣就賺不完 是90度的
因為AI會自己改進AI
來 我們再跟你講一個最誇張的
我很會問問題
像我們今天
我們研究團隊在訓練的時候
甚至福利社製作團隊訓練的時候
他說這個OpenAI GPT-6 Astra
我之前好像吃過一家餐廳
叫AD Astra是不是
天啊 預約要等一年
很誇張 好 扯遠了
我們不是幫他打廣告
人家介紹我去的
來 我不知道大家有沒有聽過
好像在晶華酒店附近
扯遠了啦
OpenAI GPT-6
怎麼樣
居然這Astra這個東西
我那時候就念那些
我就念我們的一些分析師 培訓分析師
還有就是已經考上分析師的
我們研究團隊裡面 整個團隊
我有台大的 光我個人的團隊裡面
台大 政大 會計
政大的 會計師的 分析師都有
我們整個團隊
我們在今天一起
順便跟福利社開會的時候
就有人說 這個OpenAI GPT-6
已達人類智商平均水準
我說什麼叫人類智商平均水準
結果他們沒有讀透 也沒問好AI
你看已經這麼優秀的人了
也沒問好AI
達人類平均水準是講抽象功能
什麼叫抽象功能
注意聽喔 什麼叫抽象推理 來
你看喔 抽象推理是從7.8變99%
來 我問你一下
我考你一下大家的智商
先不要看右邊
不要看喔 你不要偷看喔
把你遮住
來 2到6
3到12 4到20
等一下 又不行了
來 考你數學 很簡單喔
這個很簡單 基本上你都會
不會的沒關係 不要緊張
2到6 這邊2到6
3到12 4到20
5到多少
很簡單吧
2到6是2乘以3等於6嘛 對不對
2乘以3等於6
3到12是3乘以4等於12
所以你左邊是2 3 4 5
右邊呢 應該說中間呢
中間是3 4 5 6
所以這邊是5乘以6等於30
所以答案是30
問號是30有沒有
這叫抽象的推論
2乘以3等於6
3乘以4等於12
4乘以5
3 4 5 6
它可以舉一反三
以前不會舉一反三
就像另外一個
還有圖像推理
現在是用文字來敘述圖像喔
紅色三角形的進出盒子
出來變藍色對不對
出來紅變藍 變正方形有沒有
圓形的會變
然後圓形的變什麼 六角形
那請問藍三角形會變多少
很簡單嘛 是不是
藍呢 可能會變什麼
變成紅色 你知道嗎
三角形呢 可能變什麼
變成那個正方形
所以可能紅正方形
這樣懂意思嗎
紅變藍 藍變紅 這樣懂不懂
增加邊數 這樣懂嗎
所以這個就是一個圖像推理
真的不懂的那慘了
現在AI也可以懂了
那你說哲哲跟以前差不了多少
有 以前有人罵AI
像那個誰
有一個好像是離開Google的
他說現在AI的趨勢是笨的
所以我覺得他們都是為了
你看連一個諾貝爾獎的
然後是有人說AI之父的人
都講過類似的話
如果你知道我要講什麼
那代表你是高水準的人
你不知道我要講什麼沒關係
因為一般人都不懂
他說AI雖然是寫大學論文對不對
可以寫大學論文 可以解SAT
可以解醫師考題
可以回答實體知識
但是其實他在猜訓練資料
他只是一個Google搜尋
我剛才Google搜尋
搜尋了解
就像我回答這個問題對不對
他是用以前的規則
看有沒有以前這種模擬考題
有沒有這種智力測驗考題
因為智力測驗考題
在網路上也可以找得到
所以他去推論
所以他是用猜的
猜以前的訓練資料
網路的訓練資料
看起來懂了 不是真的懂
他沒有獨立思考
可是現在GPT-6 Astra是什麼
真正推理能力
他可以考驗現場悟出
就是我剛才講的什麼2變12
是真正了解新規則
這就不是AI了
這就不是以前你所謂的AI了
這不同在哪邊
他可以了解第二層的思考
譬如說他不會像航運股
航運股在跌下去的時候
我本益比那麼低 我要繼續買
不會 他可能會獨立思考
現在雖然本益比很低
但是未來EPS可能下滑
他懂第二層資料
為什麼利多出盡
以前不懂
他只會跟你講越跌越買
因為本益比很低
這叫第一層思考
他可以了解第二層思考
現在股價可不可以
已經反映現在的EPS了
現在股價下跌
是不是已經要反映未來的EPS了
他是第二層思考
這樣連我都緊張了
沒有關係
因為你最後還是需要我來做決定
我不怕
因為我有AI 我會用AI
我再跟你講 你們不會用AI
你們各行各業不會用AI
你們會被很多人取代
你要相信我 我是為你們好
做任何都是一樣
各行各業都是一樣
所以他現在真的懂
沒有分析師跟你解釋這個東西
他們根本不懂什麼叫AI
哪能像我這樣輕鬆解釋這些 懂嗎
以前就連諾貝爾獎
發明那個AI之父
他都說現在AI的走勢是錯誤的
我記得他講這種話
他說你只是在猜訓練資料
你不是真的AGI 你懂嗎
就是你只是在猜而已
他只是看起來好像懂
但是他只是用Google搜尋資料
答出一個最適的解
不是 現在他是真的可以獨立思考
他可以舉一反三 舉一反四
可以現場悟出新規則能力
這很恐怖 這真的叫AGI
你們不懂
沒關係 我懂就好
很恐怖
所以就像我講的直線發展
別人笑我太瘋癲
我跟你講 趕快買 真的
你真的要謝謝台灣股市
現在還沒10萬點
真的 他們那些
可不可以變現
都已經要AGI了
你還問我能不能變現
他那個成長不是網路慢慢鋪
你知道嗎
他程式已經跑很快 你懂不懂
10萬點真的是可以
我不要說一定 你知道嗎
這個跟大家講
那最新的八卦 來
你看助理做事情
你看我們有AI
你告訴我哪個老師做AI圖
你們說 你們自己回答
是不是你看那麼多分析師
是不是我們摩爾做AI圖最漂亮
然後我做圖最漂亮
0050成分股新增的股票
你看助理很快告訴我
藥華藥 很多人預期藥華藥
所以雀屏中選
剔除3661世芯
這都反映了 所以沒什麼
世芯被剔除了 來 有沒有
然後藥華藥 要不要
我跟你講 我支持台灣
我支持台灣投資生技股
但是我不支持散戶買生技股
因為你的消息沒有人家靈通
認命 好不好
我再講一次 我支持台灣
比如說有錢人 我分散投資
你懂不懂
宣明智 我分散投資生技股 支持
用閒錢支持
散戶你只有這一筆錢
不要投資生技股
我講的是實在話
盡量不要投資
要投資你也是要投資部分 好不好
言盡於此 聽不聽是你的事情
人在做天在看
我支持台灣生技股
當然因為台灣有太多生技股
是你要消息 你要有內線
你有什麼內線
奶油餅都不知道你有沒有吃到內餡
來 這個跟大家講
藥華藥 這個就最新的
這兩個沒什麼好講的 就這樣
我們看一下
只有0050嗎 助理
今天是什麼
導播幫我拿過來
所以你看全台灣第一個有理財行事曆
會把CPI 把0050成分股算進去的
就只有我
今天幾月 9月對不對
9月今天台灣50季度調整
台灣50季度調整 助理
應該也有0056吧 沒有嗎
沒有高股息成分股嗎
趕快幫我做一張圖 高股息成分股
你看這邊有寫
今天寫台灣50季度調整
我這個真的很棒
今天有寫台灣50季度調整 對不對
然後還有寫
今天晚上8點半非農就業率
非農跟那個就業數據 跟失業率
真的有這個真的很棒
來 我們來看一下
我們講到這個東西 我們順便來看一下
這個很重要
因為那個華許新任主席
在上個禮拜Jackson Hole暗示
就是要看最近的
他沒有直接講
他說要看數據
這個數據只要看兩種
一個就是就業數據
就是今天晚上公布很重要
另外一個是下禮拜五的CPI
下禮拜一休息對不對
下禮拜五的CPI
我講的休息是美股休息
下禮拜五的CPI 記起來
跟這禮拜五的非農就業數據 來看一下
記得我這句話
你看今天要47000了
43000可惜 47000可憐
9月1號的時候快47000
等到50000的時候
你還空手叫可悲
記得我這句話
來 而且連續3年了
都是我買進台灣50 公開買喔
都買在相對最低點
公開買 你不要懷疑
跌8000多點的時候
在39000的時候 厲害吧
現在漲了7000多點了
等一下喔
CPI
對 非農就業數據我們看一下
預計8月只有增5.6萬人對不對
摩根大通警示標普500
或隨數據大波動
我現在才看到這個新聞
我今天開會有跟他們講今天這個很重要
的確 為什麼你知道嗎
因為今天這個數據 來
今天晚上8點半
跟下個禮拜五晚上8點半
他會決定9月要不要升息
9月要升息股市就可能會崩
崩一下子 來個崩崩
9月不升息股市就會噴 OK嗎
所以8月非農就業數據
如果失業率維持4.1%
這是最新的喔
失業率會維持4.1%有沒有
失業率走勢4.1%
那也沒有很好
就業數據要怎麼樣
要差一點點比較好 記得
如果維持4.1% OK
那失業率到4.2% OK
可是失業率有時候不準
因為失業率有時候取決於什麼
我預期想要找工作的人
如果預期想要找工作的人怎麼樣
變少了 就是我不想找工作了
明明是我不想找工作喔
可是失業率反而下滑
我不想找工作 一群人不想找工作
失業率要增加 不是
他不列入失業率裡面
分母跟分子都減少的情況之下 記起來
分母跟分子減少的情況下
失業率還下滑
我不想找工作
我幾十萬人增加不想找工作
反而失業率下滑
所以失業率有時候不準
要看他不想找工作的人有沒有增加
這樣懂嗎
那嚴格來算的話
如果失業率提高是好事 至少不會升息
升息機率下滑
那預期上漲
2026年 上個月是少2.3萬人
預期增加5.6萬人
這個就不用想那麼多
這個是越多越不好
為什麼 我就說了
景氣不能太好 太好會升息
所以預期5.6萬人
要小於5.6萬人才會增加
如果一下子預期5.6萬人
然後變成4萬人
那股市會波動很大
一定會先崩
崩了以後會不會拉起來 這不知道
崩了以後跌的機率還是比較高
再講一次喔
今天最重要的是非農就業數據
因為他不用像失業率
失業率你不能只看失業率
你要看願意參與的找工作的人數
是增加還減少
聽不懂剛才那一段
你再重複聽兩次
直接看這個就好了
所以你直接看這個
這個就不用想那麼多
我就業人口
非農就業人口增加5.6萬人
如果再增加的話
那表示景氣很好
那可能股市會先崩再說
那會不會崩整晚
取決於譬如說我增加20萬人 那慘了
股市會稍微下去一點點
當然也有另外一波買盤會說
那經濟真的很好
雖然通膨但是可以接受
那可能還有買盤
可是我可以確定 來 記住
如果預期5.6萬人
結果少於5.6萬人
那股市會噴出去
就是景氣太好 股市先跌再說
跌了會不會拉起來 我不敢確定
可是會先跌再說
8點半的時候台指期會先跌再說
可是低於5.6萬人
那股市就會漲一整天
是低越多越好
譬如說我預期5.6萬人要增加就業
結果實際上還是減了1萬人
變成少1萬人增加就業
就是少1萬人就業
那不得了 股市會噴整晚
噴整晚又受不了
可能你會受不了
我還可以 這什麼話
這個話是要讓你記得啦
別人笑我太瘋癲 我笑他人看不穿
所以數字越小
這個非農就業數據
數字越小 股市越會噴
OK嗎 我很肯定
基本上我是很肯定語氣跟你講
我很肯定的語氣
你要知道我的邏輯跟人家不一樣
這樣有沒有聽懂
你看我們做的圖都特別漂亮
今天講的總經差不多這樣子
Astra有沒有
AI能力已經達人類水平 有沒有
就是這個新聞
Yahoo這個新聞
我今天就念爆那群分析師 培訓分析師
什麼是達人類水平 你不能這樣講
什麼是達人類水平 抽象的能力
理解抽象的能力 你懂不懂
AGI時代
所以之前有人吐槽
甚至有發明AI的人
他說沒辦法達到AGI
錯了 我們換條路還是可以
把那些一群高智商的人又啪啪啪了
AI很恐怖
之前還有人辯論這個東西
現在已經沒有問題了
很變態
你們根本不懂
AI會取代你們人生差多少
我告訴你 我已經看到未來了
以後會有很多人在那個行業失業
是真的 你們趕快保護自己 要投資AI
相信我講的話
我很少肯定跟你講
這個比那個
那時候我叫你買口罩
我說1年內有疫苗
還更肯定 好不好
來 助理剛才講
對 0056是半年調整一次
這次沒有調整
助理跟我們講這個東西 來
助理這個東西 你想看一下
助理你看很快的做圖
你看這些都是AI
你看以前有辦法做這些圖嗎
助理做得也是很快
我們看一下 去年是
今年 你看今年就好 你自己看
光Gemini有沒有看到
Google 7月一個版本
8月一個版本 9月一個版本
不覺得很恐怖嗎
本來是 有沒有看到
最近僅隔三週 有沒有看到
三週就再來一次
有沒有覺得很恐怖
3.6 3.7 3.8
發展越來越快 有沒有看到
所以很恐怖 很恐怖
所以你看他們為什麼
這一堆都在更新版本 你要懂啊
你們 有些人
史上最強的 現在最強的數學家
是不是
昨天那位陶數學家
然後陶哲軒嗎 是不是
我怕講錯了很沒禮貌
他都承認了
他已經贏不了AI 這是事實 OK嗎
記得我說的這些話 等一下
等一下 我們看一下 先看一下
我們看一下大家
我跟大家互動一下 喜歡跟你們互動
最喜歡你們了 來
今天這樣懂嗎
我今天講很多
昨天跟今天我講很多AI的東西
我是預言家
我不喜歡當一般的分析師
那個ABF載板 那個產能多少
講一堆奇怪的數字 PCB幹嘛
那個我隨便一個研究員都可以做
現在不用研究員
我大學生都可以做資料
我問AI就好啦
那些資訊不重要
我要的是看到未來
我有這個能力
我絕對是你遇到最會問問題的人
應該是 因為我不知道你認識多少人
你看我講什麼話
我都很注重邏輯上的講法
我們看一下
哲哲緯穎怎麼樣
前天進場500了
以後不用看財報
財報本來就有點過去式
你們看營收就好了 看財報來不及
現在AI時代不要看財報
你要看財報可以
比如說你預期毛利率72%
怎麼會變69%
你可以看一下 你懂嗎
看財報是預防地雷股 你懂不懂
基本上你已經分散投資OK了
哲哲太棒了 可以唱一首歌嗎
最近散熱 散熱有講啊
為什麼散熱最近漲停
微軟好像有講
就是全面攻液冷 這個新聞有差
今天直播人數6800 再多一點吧
昨天沒跟上華新科 氣死
我跟你講啦
你們沒有買被動元件 這個叫什麼
不是我要怪你們啦
如果我已經叫你買了 你不買
我沒叫你買就算了
如果我叫你買你不買 那活該
我用活該兩個字很過分 但是事實
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
好不好 真的啦
哲哲5萬點環球晶有機會2000嗎
5萬點以下就到了
5萬多啦好不好
有機會啦 5萬多啦 好不好
你這個難度很高耶
因為現在環球晶連1000塊都還沒到
1000塊以下的環球晶記得買好不好
OK嗎
很難預測 你還給我時間軸
他有可能大盤先上5萬
環球晶才跟上
也有可能還沒到5萬的時候
環球晶就先跟上了 你懂嗎
對 我幹嘛給你回答這個問題
這是會員問題耶
你不要吊我的問題啦 好不好
今天還沒看到你拍桌 可以拍一下
這樣可以嗎
威武 沒有啦
拍什麼拍
來 你活該
不要這樣想啦 沒關係啦
投資長是我恩公
那個龔先生 你最近常常跑出去
我們摩爾的其他分析師喔
不會啦 參加別人我也不會怎麼樣
昨天買南亞科好後悔 應該買國巨的
南亞科的問題就是在高基期
我就不想買高基期 慢慢賺嘛
南亞科有什麼好後悔 南亞科還是很強
南亞科很強啦 漲那麼多
其實國巨你不一定要買
我是你 我可能買華新科
因為華新科上面籌碼比較簡單
賣壓沒那麼重 這個跟大家講
當然慢慢會缺貨了
像有些外資喊1000多塊
我幹嘛理他1000多塊
我先賺到800元可不可以
國巨賺800元
再把華新科出掉就好了
這樣懂不懂 你自己對照一下
到時候華新科多少錢嘛
OK嗎 來
群聯NAND Flash控制晶片
與客製化韌體
他現在有在客製化這些東西
投資朋友 他講的有道理
很多人幹嘛
我一定要跟雲端的AI伺服器結合
我自己跑AI軟體可不可以
群聯做這個事是對的啦
群聯這個EPS還是有機會增加啦
好不好
一家老闆認真做事有差啦
我覺得還是認真做事啦 好不好 來
謝謝哲哲 我最喜歡這句話
你好 哲哲
你們訊息跑好快 太多人了
哲哲謝謝你
讓我補了國巨快要脫身了
從1000下來補完到現在602
你們一直補嘛
500元就補 400元就補
補到這樣是不是
一直補到最後 你看他補很多
為什麼1000元可以補到602
很簡單嘛
我1000元買一張
我400多元買十張可不可以
補完現在成本變602 你隨時會賺錢
你看我們這裡有一個成功案例喔
因為他開始一直補補補
逢低就加碼 逢低就加碼
但是我還是建議不要超過5成
超過5成 不關我的事
基本上你都不能
都不要賺錢沒有人謝謝我 賠錢怪我
記得 只是說5成以上
就風險比較高
大戶天天丟2到3萬張
散戶還狂買
有時候散戶是對的喔
就像有時候行情破底的時候
都是散戶在買 外資在買
哪有什麼對跟錯 螞蟻雄兵啊
是不是 哪有什麼對跟錯
我跟哲哲買0050賺了100萬
不好意思 我賺了1500到1600
不過我不是重點 我是要捐救護車的
2700買的群聯有沒有救
我覺得有救喔
土木技師會取代嗎
我還不太了解土木技師 我不會亂講話
我再強調一件事
會用土木技師的
土木技師應該要畫圖嘛 是不是
會用 如果說現場的水電
比較不會被取代啦
因為水電工越來越貴
土木技師 會用AI的土木技師
一定會取代不會用AI的土木技師
像我剛才那個立面圖啊
人家可能要畫一整天的時間
不好意思 AI一秒鐘
你怎麼跟人家PK
人家可以殺價競爭你啊 對不對
OK 好啦 現在幾分
45 我們趕快看一下股票
5347世界先進有沒有
我跟你講到時候600多元
你就知道我的厲害了
來看一下鴻海
鴻海今天不錯喔
我最恐怖的是這個啦 2377
我一直在想要不要再加碼
我之前有買啦
可是我現在股票不想追高
就是如果我170以下沒有買
沒有再買的話
我基本上就不會再買了
因為就連170買都有點高
他也不是真的很高
就他週線來看的話
你看週線以前200元
我的高是最近期新高
所以為什麼
你告訴我為什麼微星那麼強
廢話 他就有點像
1 200元的欣興一樣啊
你懂我在說什麼嗎
買低基期的股票 各位 懂不懂
買低基期的股票 微星
技嘉也是低基期的
所以這些電子股有在漲喔
偷漲喔 不一樣喔 好不好
2454聯發科我覺得可以投資
可以再投資
因為輝達有加碼有差
我覺得輝達加碼以後 你看一下
除非台股大崩盤
基本上3000元不會跌破啦
記得這句話 再講一次
基本上我覺得3000元不會跌破
一年內除非這個大崩盤
就是台灣股市整個崩了
就是跌破到3萬多點
37000點以下
就算37000點 我都覺得
就算台灣股市現在
殺到37000 38000
我都覺得它不會碰到3000元
不現在之前碰到3000元
碰到2990元 記得我這句話
基本上回到3000元機率不高了
好不好 OK嗎
3000元機率不高
一定要記得我這句話
因為有輝達的加持 一定要記得
不敢說百分之百
但是這是我個人看法
帆宣也是一樣喔 有沒有
資本支出又增加快2倍了 有沒有
慢慢漲 有沒有
還有3374 我記得有些股票
助理怎麼沒寫
精材你看
幸好哲哲那時候
有拜託一下主管機關
現在主管機關順應民意
怎麼樣 現在2分鐘交易一次
以前這種股票根本不敢這樣拉
就算一直被處置也沒差
精材要漲真的啦
今天最興奮的不是國巨
不是被動元件 是精材跟微星
我還是有股票好強 要創新高
精材創一個收盤價新高了啦
雖然9月1號有更高的股價 431
但是今天給你拉這個尾盤
我信心十足
我精材要賺大錢 我好興奮啊
我跟你講到時候賺大錢
你不要不理我
我今天講從總經面
從跟你講這些升息
跟你講就業數據 CPI 0050
我超多基本面的
哪有像我這樣講
還有我跟你講的什麼
那個被動元件的缺貨潮
還有什麼是Astra
就是最新的Gemini
還有最新的ChatGPT
什麼叫做抽象邏輯能力
什麼叫做通用人工智慧
我都跟你解釋了耶
以前 你知道嗎
這個因為你們很多人不懂AI
最恐怖是以前一直覺得
這些AI不是真的AI
他不會懂到通用人工智慧
他沒有抽象能力的思考
結果不是耶
他這個模型
打臉了很多諾貝爾獎的想法
那AI真的很恐怖
進步到很恐怖
這一年時間發生了多少事情
每三個禮拜一個新的型態出現
一個新的模型出現
你們還搞不清楚
這一段最好賺 我告訴你喔
從台灣股市4萬點到10萬點很好賺
再講一次 4萬點到10萬點很好賺
10萬點以後我不知道
今朝有酒今朝醉
現在台灣都去日本購物
以前十年河東十年河西
以前日本排計程車你要給他小費
不然你叫不到計程車啊
1990年代 你問你媽媽
以前最媚日 最崇日
比喜歡韓國還更誇張
以前日本人多有錢
台灣現在也是這樣子
可是台灣會不會過20年後
變成像日本這樣
我不知道 重點是什麼
你要在泡沫
就算真的以後AI泡沫了
在崩盤之前
你至少要存一大筆錢
不要說崩盤
就是景氣沒有那麼好的時候
你賺一大筆錢
不然你會後悔一輩子
你知道我最喜歡讀歷史故事的
你知道嗎
我昨天看了一下亂世佳人
我想說為什麼
我喜歡看歷史
史上最賣座
我看蜘蛛人好像賣了2 30億美金
史上最強大 最賣座
不是鐵達尼號
如果算通貨膨脹 亂世佳人
我在看這些東西
為什麼講這個 人性啦
困苦的時候
人好的時候 亂世佳人那個女主角
人好的時候
本來是南方大地主的女兒
後來不是了
人性的改變 你知道嗎
好的時候的想法跟不好的時候
景氣好的時候跟景氣不好的時候
想法差很多
我也要告訴你
你們不要覺得現在賺錢很簡單
就是以後賺錢很簡單
你現在不把握行情
你會後悔一輩子啦 我告訴你
現在真的很好賺啦
以後我不知道啦
真的啦 什麼叫好賺
你看AI進步就知道了
那個很誇張啦
不要去聽那些人講那什麼AI泡沫
他不懂AI啦
他有沒有像我一樣
每天問個幾十題問題啊 真的啦
我給你介紹那AI
有分析師跟你講這個東西嗎
根本不懂啊
什麼叫抽象邏輯思考
他連抽象都不知道
我沒騙你啦 好不好
國巨你看喔
不離不棄 是我兄弟
勇者無懼 就等國巨 就漲停了
哪有人像我這樣
兼具有Guts 遠見的人
講下去我自己都不好意思 臉要紅了
好不好
這個精材要噴出去 你自己看
助理怎麼沒精材的簡訊啊 有沒有
來不及對不對
有 恭喜3374精材
幾分了 我要結束了
恭喜3374精材
股價處置照樣噴出大漲超過6%
我已經賺了118%
財富翻倍 我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續抱
精材是如此 有沒有看到
國巨也是如此 有沒有看到 漲停
華新科也漲停 持股獲利續抱
有華新科的通通賺錢
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
趕快這個行情要噴出去了
整理要完畢了
趕快來電洽詢080066885
或者加我的LINE私訊我說
哲哲我要賺大錢
私訊我 哲哲會費怎麼算
我答應你
我竭盡我所能來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位